your value theorem tells you is that if
you have a continuous graph meaning that
you're not picking up your pen there's
no breaks in the graph it's like you can
drag your pencil or pen along the graph
without picking it up that you know if
you're to go from let's say this point
right here to this point right here okay
you're gonna hit all the Y values in
between this y coordinate and that y
coordinate because it's not like all of
a sudden you're gonna just like pick up
your pen and then move it to here if
it's continuous you're gonna again
you're gonna hit all the Y values that
are in between the y coordinate at this
point and the y coordinate this point
because it's continuous but the
application how we use intermediate
value theorem when we're working with
polynomials and finding zeros okay zeros
are where the graph crosses the x axis
is that say we're given a table like so
notice here are some X values here are
some Y values notice the Y value is
positive positive positive negative so
what happened here between negative 1 &
0
well the graph had to go from positive 1
to negative 2 let's draw a graph of that
ok just to get a sense of this so if we
were to plot these points let's see
negative 3 1 2 3 4 okay so that would be
right up here negative 2 6 5 6 here up
to here negative 1 1 we're down to here
0 we're at negative 2 okay so if this is
a continuous graph that means this graph
say for example it's like this right and
what's happening so between x equals
negative 1 okay and x equals zero in
between these two x coordinates the
graph is going from positive to negative
so that means in between negative 1 & 0
there must be a zero meaning an x
intercept the graph has to cross the
x-axis okay if we continue along here we
go negative
positive okay again we're going from a
negative Y value to a positive Y value
so in between 1 & 2 there must also be a
zero okay and then we go from positive
to positive positive positive it's not
crossing the x-axis it's only when it
changes from positive to negative or
from negative to positive do we know
that the graph is crossing the x-axis
and that you're going to have a zero or
an intercept or a root or a solution
however you want to say it and these are
the x-coordinates that 0 is going to
occur between